[Musique]
la filière boî goyavier continue son
ascension et s'attaque au marché
international plusieurs agents on
travaillaient d'arracheepied pour
élaborer divers produits destiné au
Salon Maison et Objets qui se déroule à
Paris c'est une nouvelle étape on va
dire qui s'insère encore plus dans le
secteur économique donc après janvier en
2016 salon Maison et Objet là on partir
sur la la deuxème étape toujours salon
Maison et Objet septembre c'est un salon
professionnel orienté sur du mobilier
d'intérieur d'extérieur du décor il y a
il y a des milliers d'exposants et
l'objectif pour nous qu on va sur sur ce
salon c'est dépasser un petit peu les
frontières du département de La Réunion
et voilà l'objectif c'est c'est de faire
connaître le gouavier maintenant sur
toute l'Europe une deuxème participation
pour aller de nouveau à la rencontre des
visiteurs et leur faire découvrir les
mil et une façon de travailler le boî
goyavier la peste végétale joue
désormais dans la cour des grands après
une transformation et un travail de
création pour élaborer de nouvelles
lignes qui donne naissance à des objets
tendanes le bois de goyavier se donne
les moyens de ses ambitions cette année
on est on a réussi à prendre un stand un
peu plus grand on sera sur 21 m² et on a
séparé cet espace ces 21 m² en deux
zones distinctes la partie varang très
typique de de de l'île réunon et là on
va retrouver du mobilier de jardin du du
des petit pergola des panneaux qui
pouront ressembler à des des cœures
qu'on va retrouver à la Réunion et
ensuite la partie
intérieure on va retrouver des tables
basses on est sur un côté un peu plus
salon des tables basses des comptoirs
toujours des fauteuils mais d' standing
un peu plus un peu plus important euh
des petits plateaux de table des choses
courantes qu'on retrouve à la maison en
fait et et qu'on qu'on met en avant
depuis depuis déjà quelques temps le
bois de goyavier porté par le
département et impulsé par Nassima
Dindar a permis d'insérer de nombreux
jaune qui possède désormais un vrai
savoir-faire et puis il y a les hommes
d'expérience comme Dominique menusier de
formation la découverte du bois de
goyavier a été une
révélationut imaginejà voilà table
banquette étagère les objets en bois de
goyavier surprennent mais surtout
séduisent par leur forme originale le
grand salon Maison et Objets se tient
donc au parc des expositions de ville
peinte début septembre 3000 marques plus
de 130 m car de stand et 70000 visiteurs
attendus pour cet événement une vitrine
et l'occasion de conquérir de nouveaux
marchés mais également de faire
connaître la
[Musique]
Réunion